miles de personas salieron a las calles
de la capital tunecina para protestar
contra el presidente que continúa
ampliando sus poderes caixa hayet ha
vuelto a indignar sus opositores al
tomar el control de la justicia el
mandatario firmó un decreto que crea un
consejo judicial temporal sin mandato
fijo para supervisar a los jueces y
eliminar su derecho a la huelga de
conformidad con este decreto se creará
un consejo que gozará de una
independencia administrativa y
financiera para supervisar los asuntos
del poder judicial y que reemplazará el
consejo supremo de la magistratura el
nuevo consejo se denominará consejo
supremo de la magistratura provisional y
tendrá su sede en túnez la medida
también otorgadas a haier la autoridad
para destituir promover o nombrar a los
magistrados y será responsable de
proponer reformas judiciales la
manifestación organizada por el partido
islamista moderado enhada y por miembros
de un grupo de la sociedad civil
el 25 de julio éramos 6 personas ahora
somos miles el 25 de julio él tenía
mucha gente detrás ahora está solo el
organismo de control judicial se
consideraba el último bloqueo
institucional que quedaba fuera del
control del presidente después de que
esté destituyera al gobierno y
suspendiera al parlamento el pasado mes
de julio antes de pasar a gobernar por
decreto
caixa que ayer anunció la sustitución
una semana después de que afirmara que
planeaba disolver el consejo lo que
provocó protestas y un cierre nacional
de los tribunales por parte de los
jueces que se oponían a la medida sakai
ed acusó al consejo de bloquear
investigaciones políticamente sensibles
y de estar influenciado por la oposición
destacó además que el decreto era
necesario para salvar a túnez de lo que
describe como una elite corrupta e
interesada que ha dañado la economía y
ha llevado al estado al borde del
colapso